هيا يا أخي الصغير،
هذا سقوط يحتاج العالم إلى
رؤيته، تعلم أن هذا هو نوع السقوط
الذي كان العالم ينتظره
أعتقد
[موسيقى]
خرجت وأشعر وكأنني حصلت على هذه
المنعطفات الجميلة  أسفل الجبل وفي المنعطفات
الخمس الأولى كان الأمر يسير بشكل
جيد جدًا،
أسقط
ثم يأخذني الفم
وأسقط وأسقط وأسقط وليس
لدي أي سيطرة، أفقد زلاجاتي في
الأعلى، أفقد كل إحساس  الاتجاه
ويهدأ في النهاية ولكن بعد ذلك
يأتي كل الثلج الذي أطلقته فوقي
ويأخذني ويأخذني على طول الطريق إلى أسفل
الجبل
للتدريب على تحديد المخاطر
وتقييم الثلج ومن ثم لدينا كل
هذه الموارد  التي نستخدمها لقراءة
رصاصات الانهيار الجليدي ثم قبل أن
نخطو إلى تضاريس الانهيار الجليدي وهي
تضاريس شديدة الانحدار بما يكفي حيث
يمكن أن يكون هناك انهيار ثلجي، نتحقق دائمًا من
أن الثلج آمن، لذا فإن هذا يشبه
القاتل الرئيسي في هذه الجبال هو
الانهيارات الثلجية  بالطبع هناك دائمًا أيضًا
خطر السقوط إلى أسفل الجبل
وهذا أمر يصعب التحكم فيه
خاصة عندما تحضر أخاك الأصغر
ولكني أعني نفسي أيضًا، أعني أنه يمكنك
دائمًا السقوط أسفل الجبل،
فهذا مجرد جزء منه ولكن كما نحن
لديك دليل الآن على
أنه يمكنك السقوط من الجبل
وستكون بخير تمامًا أوه شكرًا لك، نعم على الرحب والسعة،
لذا أه نعم الخطر الرئيسي الانهيارات الجليدية الخطر الثاني
الدببة القطبية الخطر الثالث السقوط
من الجبل ومثل هذا النوع
من المخاطر ومن ثم نحن  اه فقط
تأكد من خلال التدريب
والتحضير الجيد أننا سنظل
بخير،
نعم
حسنًا، تعليقات أمهاتنا،
تعليقات أمنا هي الأكثر أهمية، فهي
لم تكن سعيدة
كما كانت والدتنا لأنني
الأخ الأكبر، لذا كانت والدتنا كذلك  كما لو أنها
مسؤوليتك، فأنت تخرجه إلى هناك
وتضعه فوق هذا الفم الكبير
ثم يسقط إذا تعرض للأذى فهذا خطأك وأنا
مثل شخص بالغ يريد أن
يكون هناك و  لا أعرف هذا ولكني
أعتقد أنها كانت في النهاية آه نعم أعتقد
أنها ضحكت في الواقع عندما أرادت ذلك
بعد نصيحة الصدمة الأولية نعم
إنه سقوط مضحك لقد سقط لمدة
دقيقة كاملة حتى والدتنا غادرت